hey everyone it's my vatos and welcome
to the odor fellas market analysis for
Thursday August 24 2017 now the previous
two Thursday's this month we had big big
Dom days and you know that was sort of
lingering in the back of my mind that
we'd get a big down day but you know
honestly I we had a kind of a quiet day
we ended up a little bit but it was
quite they and I kind of anticipated
that happening because you got the Janet
Yellen speaking tomorrow on Friday at
the Jackson Hole conference and you got
a bunch of central bankers there and but
really everyone's gonna be listening to
Janet Yellen tomorrow she speaks at I
think starting at 9:00 a.m. Central time
and they go look for any hints of when
the central banks may begin to unwind
their stimulus and also tomorrow we got
tomorrow I'll be in Friday we got also
durable goods at 7:30 but I think you
really the the focus will be on Janet
Yellen speaking anyway that said let's
jump into it there's still some great
great moves in the espys crude oil yen
and some interesting things in the
European market which I'll talk about so
let's jump into it first a brief
disclaimer this presentation is for
educational and informational purposes
only and should not be considered a
solicitation of I or sell a futures
contract or make any other type of
investment decision future trade contain
substantial risk and it's not for every
investor and investor could potentially
lose all or more than the initial
investment risk capital is money that
could be lost not jeopardizing one's
financial security or lifestyle only
risk capital should be used for trading
and only those was sufficient risk
capital should consider trading past
performance it's not necessarily
indicative of future results the tools
we used in this presentation are the
order flows trader it's a volume
footprint chart with additional
indicators added to it to help you read
the order flow things like single prints
things like stacked imbalances things
like ratios which I developed but now
everyone is seems to be copying so you
know that there's a little victory for
me in that that you know at least I
introduced something to the order flow
or the trading world in general and even
though I don't get the credit for it but
you know people that know me know no I
was the originator of it so and the
other tool is is the Delta scalper which
is a additional tool to read the Delta
and analyze it for trading opportunities
shift since
and demand so that said like I said you
know ESPYs offered some really great
trading opportunities and let me just
get the chart up here for you I know
which one to start with ten range best
I'll show you the ten range I'll show
you the four range it was really pretty
clear on the ten range early mmm this
high here just after the cash open okay
you were railing up most of the morning
you get up here to do this new high at
this party thirty five right after the
cash you make a new high you know you've
got positive things in here you got
buying imbalances and you know that
that's a good sign of a market that's
going up but you got this negative Delta
okay which kind of worries me you know
whenever you're at a high and you got
negative Delta that to me that's the
sign say hey you know look deeper into
what's going on in here now you could I
do know that this bar straddled you know
from seven forty six until eight thirty
five so ISM you know close to an hour's
fifteen minutes more or less so there
was a lot of activity pre-cache open so
there was a lot of selling in here you
know a lot of time you know most of this
bar was negative Delta so I knew that
there was some sign in here precache
open ones cash opens things really
change you know I mean that's when those
index our guys are gonna start training
now because they're gonna be doing it
against the cash and you know cash
markets not open so they're not trading
that's why you see more volume come in
after the cash open that's why in cash
open is very important so anyway we open
up and we make a new high we get this
new high we got this bar here very
bearish bar we've got a point of control
up near the top you've got negative
Delta - mm it's more than the previous
bar you got these solid balances and
this is a little bit of a more advanced
thing but analyzing the numbers actually
in the bar again you know with order
flow you don't necessarily need to
always analyze every single print that
goes through like you would with a dome
but you can look back and take a
snapshot of the market at this time and
you can see in here very thin volumes
you know you have the heavy volume at
the top
then look on this move down you know 500
200 400 300 400 it's nothing major even
here you got six lots it's very thin
volume it's almost like a gap inside the
bar so you got three imbalances you got
the negative Delta point of control near
the top you got the divergence that's
already negative next bar so you're not
convinced yet uh Mike you know you're
kook I don't I don't believe it
next bar you got the ratio the bearish
ratio after the high with the divergence
again that that's another signal to be
looking to get short and then in here
you see four hundred five thousand two
thousand you see you know start you see
imbalances selling imbalances you don't
see buying imbalances on the way up you
see buying imbalances I moves up you see
buying imbalances I move down you see
selling imbalances that's just how it
goes I mean it doesn't get any more
clearer than that you know you know why
on moves up you have buying imbalances
because you have aggressive buyers why I
moves down you have sound bounces
because you have aggressive sellers and
you know just sort of going back here I
looted to you know the thin volume
compare the volumes here or 500 you know
I know we're between 200 to 500 you know
normally you in the bars you you should
be getting you know on a 10 range chart
in the SPS or you know even on a 4 range
chart you're getting no thousands
trading at a level so I know the market
is selling off pretty quick you know
it's pretty aggressive selling not much
buying company hurt where are people
coming in here supporting this market
putting bins in they're not you know
that they're there but hasn't been to
work any bids there hasn't to be buyers
up here so then the market starts
selling off right but again you know
this bar was already bearish this next
bar confirms it and you get this move
you get this move from you know the 44
area all the way down eventually to the
38 37 s but you know that was a to me
that was an easy one you know that was
when I pointed out in the room and I
started very a nice a nice trading
opportunity eventually later you came
down you made a new low down here that's
bar right off the low you got to Delta
scalper and your rally back up again you
know another five points on the way back
up but again you know is there anything
else in this bar besides this Delta
scalper here and you know you got a lot
of it buying imbalances alright you
don't see any selling imbalances on
move down all you see the sound
imbalances while some binding balances
start appearing off the low that's
important just since you had Pakistan
imbalance appearing off the high that's
important information again you could
read the Delta what do you got here -
$3,000 so it's quite strong early in the
bark very strong ends up at - 232 so
this it went from a very strong negative
Delta to you know almost a positive
Delta finishing you know ended up at
negative 232 it's still so it's still
negative that that's fine I know that it
once at - 3,000 but an additional 3,000
came back in aggressive buying and you
know settle it at about unchanged more
or less and then next bar Delta scalper
next you know three imbalances three
imbalances here so you know buy
aggressive buying is coming in and then
you get it's nice rally up from this low
you know what I mean that sets the
beauty of reading order flows you'll
read in the delta reading the imbalances
you know putting these things together
it's you know this one you don't have
the point of control at the high also
had the point of control adding adding
to it as well you know so that there are
signs in the order flow again if you're
just looking at a normal a normal bar
chart you're not necessarily going to
see that information you know at all
because you know the part charts don't
don't read that information now on the
for range chart that high it was a lot
more obvious go back to it here you know
you could have gotten in a little bit
sooner again you don't have the ratio on
the high you got the point of control
near the high you've got the divergence
next bar the ratio you know this is a
trade I talked about every single day
every single day ratio and divergence
and you see how it's sold off
boom-boom-boom imbalances right what do
you got
buying balances or selling imbalances
you got selling the balances right up at
the high boom boom boom it comes down
and then you get to this bar we start
coming back up buying and balance here
buying and balance here then what
happens there's no more buying it just
drops you see the thin volume 400 131 90
then the aggressive selling comes back
in here so you know
sold off from the high you can see your
coming down here you got a ratio bonds
low which is bullish you got a buying a
balance again that's bullish carries
over into the next party you still got
aggressive buying what about you got
1900 2000 buying balance aggressive
buyers where's the follow-through it's
not there instead you get when you get
whacked here are three thousand selling
a balance thin volume here we just get
slammed down here pretty quick get into
the next bar more buying imbalances more
by Saudi selling it bounces more selling
and balances and you just keep trading
lower lower lower so you know you could
have got into this move on the for range
of a bit sooner than the 10 range but
again it was is essentially this the
same thing ratio and divergence you
getting some confirmation thing you read
you know you just don't look at a chart
and say you know look for arrows to be
flashing you know with order flow yeah I
think all right you got to put the
pieces of the puzzle together and when
you see things like this right you see
it come off the high start to rally up a
little bit you got the green bar you got
the bullish ratio you got buying in
balance next Mart buying in balance but
then it gets slammed in here like this
with the big selling of balance and then
another selling balance and even the
next bar selling a bouncy you know that
markets not going up anymore you could
aggressively get short there and you
know if you do you know we sell off
another you know all the way down you
know the how many points that is five
points more or less that excuse me so
let's take a look at the the low of the
day here on the for range you know
compared to the 10 range on the 10 range
you don't necessarily see it I started
on the 4 means you don't necessarily
what you saw in the 10 range again you
got the the big bar with the negative
Delta just before it this one yeah you
know it's -5 89 ends up at 74 yeah that
that's encouraging it's same thing in
the next part with next bar as a doji
bar then the bar here you got the
stacking balance on the 10 range it
looked a little bit cleaner because you
also had the Delta scalper coming in
here you don't have the Delta scalper
coming in off this low in here you know
before you rally back up but you know
the 10 range go back to it
you know it was a bit more clearer here
with the Delta scalper and and the shift
in the Delta then it was with the with
the for range okay so next next we'll
take a look at crude no crude was
interesting this morning again well okay
here okay
so you got a ratio and divergence right
off the low well you know Delta scalper
the next bar you get a nice little move
up now not the biggest move it's about
you know about 20 ticks but also earlier
there's something here I thought there
was maybe that was the one else I made a
note to talk about it or is this high up
here actually so we rally up from this
low here okay if you could see it make
the chart a little easier to read so you
know off the slow you got a divergence
you could make the argument with a delta
you know minus 600 ended up at plus 165
you know that's a nice sign that's a
nice sign again with the Delta where it
it changes internally rallies up when we
get up here get within a tick of the
high you can't take out the highs and
get within one tick of it you know a
small negative Delta this is the Delta
surge right here this this here you can
see how it's getting bigger is 30 61 301
598 so you know the selling is coming in
here right you know we just tested the
high we got within one tick of the high
we couldn't break that high all of a
sudden selling starts coming in okay so
again you ask yourself every time you
get up near a high is this market gonna
go higher or not and look for signs if
it is it look for signs if it isn't and
what do you got it's now you got signs
that it isn't gonna hold it isn't gonna
go higher it's gonna sell off how it's
in the Delta right here 61 301 598 and
when you do you just sell off one will
move into and down into the new lows new
lows no reason we
be buying here yeah you haven't dealt
escape or just go sideways on you though
this is the Delta surge again right
they're sort of hanging around no reason
to be buying down there off this off the
slow you got the ratio and divergence
here at 9:37 again you get a small move
about 20 ticks before the market comes
back down people say well the market
came back down well yeah it did why
because you read the order flow what's
happening you rally up here you get to
this high okay 94 sell off a bit start
coming back up you get this bar here you
thinking okay hey we're making it if
you're still in this trade you shouldn't
be got Delta Scot Marciel here but say
you're still in this trade you know
you're still long you're getting a sign
here maybe this mark it's gonna go back
up because you got some buying
imbalances well hold on next bar 1 2 3 4
imbalances so everything that was in
this bar that was nice is wiped out with
this next bar so again you'll say you're
still in this trade say you're still
long and you're staring at this bar like
this pointing control up near the top
you know it's kind of a double top here
less volume and then for you know you
got four imbalances in the bar that's
not a good sign that this markets going
higher if anything that's more of a sign
of the markets gonna sell off and then
you do boom down into new lows down into
new lows then off this low again you
start seeing some signs you got the
divergence but no ratio you got the
ratio on the next bar you got the Delta
scalper again do you get a movement out
really it's about a 10 tick move more or
less then you come you know they start
going sideways Delta scalper gives the
sell we sell off and down into these new
lows down here then you know off the low
this is the u-turn indicator here this
black arrow right off the low what do
you get Delta scalper giving you a buy
you know run the you know you getting
along around 18 16 17 18 and it makes a
nice move he'll back up back up back up
back up to the close all the way up to
the close and we're even higher in the
evening session but still you
get in from 18 and say you just getting
out with this bar which is I should be
bearish bar right here in terms of the
ratio of say you're getting out
somewhere in here so you know it's 30
ticks so does a decent move there
the yen talked about the end really
quick I said you know in general is kind
of a quiet day but there was still some
decent moves to be had you know I don't
I'd seen it it's it's a quiet day
because the other that's sort of
disingenuous that you know makes you
think that you know the markets didn't
really have much of a movement when
wouldn't in reality they did you know
where are we here I'm just looking at
this this is right now in the evening
session times at 8:43 one returning
91/30 okay so a little bit lower but
going back to these lows this morning in
the end here we are what do you have you
know on the broken record again you got
ratio and divergence right here you get
a small little move up not the greatest
move about you know about ten full ticks
come back down here 750 ratio and
divergence again you know from ninety
one forty eight you know all the way up
into the 60s
68 up here you start seeing some signs
this was interesting up here I found
this to be quite bearish this actually
this the set up this morning you just
sort of you come up here and you just
start getting these small Delta's 2469
2:30 and then that's the big this
selling just comes right in here and
yeah just mark it just gets slammed back
down Delta scalper kicks off as well and
again you move down from the other 63
area down into the the you know 50s
you got the Delta scalper here this one
just goes sideways on you here's the
price reject you're given a by Delta
scalp or uh sorry Delta surge right here
you know it's helping confirm this move
back up you know you got a nice rising
Delta as you're starting to move back
higher
so you know that was about it for the
end that was interesting there's some
other interesting things you know really
quick here you got point control up near
the top here you got this selling
imbalance followed up with the stack
behind a balance fortunately this market
just went sideways normally I find that
to be a nice trading opportunity you
know I said you got the imbalance mine
and balance up off the low which is also
encouraging but it just couldn't muster
the move and selling came right back in
and you made new lows going into the
close lastly I thought about ones ones
interesting morning again you know I
like buns you know people always asked
me hey what markets can I trade you know
I got a full-time job I want to trade I
wanna get some screen time in and they
always say I can't trade it you know I
can't trade these markets cuz you know
it's too thin in the morning well you
trade buns
you know buns are ones used to be the
most liquid contract in the world
actually until really the immunities
started taking off but buttons you know
back in the late 90s early 2000s used to
be trading you know over a million
contracts that was back when s appease
were you know not even trading a million
so buns are ones our nice contractor
trade the European the German contracts
like buns euro stock Co stocks are a bit
slow but Dax
you know Dec says tax is a margin hog
full margin on that is 24,000 around
there but buns art is a nice it's a term
it's a tenure I can't I find my darn bun
chart I'm gonna close it you know
sometimes I take screenshots of stuff
and then you know the screenshot after I
save it and I sometimes I forget to
close it then it's staring on my screen
and it looks like an actual chart and
then now you realize it's just a
screenshot and I gotta close it I look
like an idiot
but um anyway let's take a look here at
the buns this morning very interesting
so early on 203 all right after the cash
open in the buns - got racial divergence
Delta scalper stack buying and balance a
lot of bullish things in this bar and
what happens it proceeds to go sideways
on you you know maybe you could have got
a ticket or two out of it but
very disappointing in terms of movement
even get the Delta scalper here a bit
later which is sort of kills the trade
and then the market sells off into the
new lows then you hit this low 164 66
no Delta no divergence because you got
the negative Delta you do have a ratio
though so I'll be looking for this
market to sort of come back to that
level either when when I have just a
naked ratio like that I often times I
expect the market to come back there and
it does you hit it again here you got a
ratio and divergence again hey that's
great let's see if we can rally you
don't you get one bar up then everything
else back down into the lows again you
got the Delta scalper here just does
nothing
Delta scalper here again it's still the
same low so you got a lot of reasons to
be buying off this low but for some
reason right now the markets not wanting
to move off that low I mean you're
getting into signs that hey this market
can really start to move off this low
Delta scalper gives a sell here you're
going into the low so you know just
watching it again you got divergence
here thinking okay maybe this market
could finally pop maybe you look for a
bullish sign in the next bar nothing in
this bar right here a ratio and
divergence finally you're getting
something look at this one lot that's
when it's important to me a single print
one launch trade there so you know you
tested this low how many times once
twice three four five times this is a
fifth time you test this low the last
time you test this low you get one lot
tells you you know someone's probing
down there seeing if they could take out
the low or trigger some stops or
something it's just not happening and
you know so now what's gonna happen you
can't take out the low eventually the
markets gonna rally you've had five
shots at the low you got a lot of
bullish signs down here again you got
you know ratio and divergence you got
Delta scalper these are right on the low
you know you mean yeah you have a delta
scalper here you got delta scupper
settle here but again looking at this
low it's got a lot of bullish reasons to
be buying here finally you know it even
if you were long back here you know
after this or off to this you wouldn't
be stopped out because you haven't made
that new low you know you'd be
frustrated as hell because you keep
coming in not going anywhere you're not
and you're not breaking but again you
know this this bar here to me it was it
was very very nice to see and what
happens finally you start getting the
move what do you do you got to move from
you know 164 70 all the way up into new
highs other way to the highest new highs
you know at at 90 so again you know if
there was any move to be had in the in
the Bible or ones you know this is it
right here
you know I mean it's unfortunate that
it's such a tight range this morning
there's about a 20 tick range 21 tick
range but you know so there's not many
ticks to be had but you know you're
talking about a move from your low up to
your high you you that you're covering
the entire range right there and it was
very obvious there in the order flow you
know eventually we came back down you
know but nobody wasn't much information
up here really to tell you to get short
up in here you know eventually we had
this nice move from your high back down
towards your lows you get down here you
got the price rejected giving you the
buy and you sort of work your way back
up a bit before you come off and settle
right you know right off your lowest but
again you know well if you'd have one
trade it was buying off this low all the
signs were there to be buying off that
low there so it's it's again it's up to
you to to recognize that and and take
those trades I mean I could sit here and
tell you yeah you gotta look for ratio
and divergence look for ratio and
divergence but if if you know if you're
not going to take them you know it's
kind of pointless to use order flow I
mean that's why you use order Falls to
see those volumes
you know the obligatory nice-looking
charts with the Delta scalper this
morning this is Dax is a one-minute
chart
nails this low one you get along at 170
all the way up into this area up here on
you know 210 you know get some small
little trades here nice little sell here
and a little bi that sort of goes a
little bit higher then you get another
nice buy here around the 115 area you
know all the way up up up into the
the two 40s unfortunately nothing no
signal here you know I would love to
show you this chart and have cell signal
there but it was just you know no signs
in the Delta and the rest of the day not
much I mean you got one late by here at
12:00 12:15 that was about it let's take
a look at some other you know obligatory
nice charts as I'd like to call them
looking for my you know again there's
that crude oil 233 tick chart thanks to
Franco who really gave me a hard time
over this I'd like to show this to see
what he's missing again you know 233
tick chart you got a very tight stop
again you're not letting it get up here
to stop you out you're getting stopped
if he's gonna get out you get out
immediately you're just looking for
short wins getting one you know here
here here here here you know possibly
here you got something here
nice move here move here not much there
get a move here move here small move
there again you just you know with the
233 tick chart you should just really be
looking for ticks rather than you know
big moves but still you're getting some
decent moves you know nice and decent
move there nothing there nothing there
something here or something here nothing
there
although you shouldn't be takin that
trade cuz you should let the market sort
of take you into the trade rather than
just all I got to buy it because there's
a signal there you know let the market
confirm it you know let it lead you in
you know it's like hunting right on
yours you know and when you're trying to
shoot the bird you don't shoot where it
is right now you shoot where it's going
to be so you know you should be letting
you know so say this is your bar here
for your entry alright you should you
know give it a tick well let it tick up
a tick or two past the close of this bar
yeah this is a nice move there so that
there are some nice moves here in the
evening session even in the evening
session it's giving you a lot of cell
signs you know boom boom
last one take a look at I'm just curious
the 987 tick charts in the in the which
we call it
ESPYs find it here now people have been
asking about Union wrinkle how it looks
with uni wrinkle it looks good but I
just don't have the chart but I I'm
going I've ever since loaded up my uni
Renko indicator and hopefully I'll get
some charts up there tomorrow I don't
know if I'm gonna have something on for
a Friday because I'm going I'm gonna be
I got a long weekend ahead of me so I
don't know if I'll be able to get a
review on for Friday or not but I'll try
to okay this is 987 tick chart so early
on after the cash open you get a bye
doesn't work out the cell yeah it starts
to work out then it comes back up then
boom you get this nice l44 down into the
you know the 37 s the cell doesn't work
out the cells small small small small
the small winner they're small winners
here here you know a little bit of a
rally here going into the close so you
know there was some decent trades to be
had all around with order flow with the
Delta scalper so again if you're
interested in wondering more about the
order flow go to my website order flows
comm go to Delta scalper be sure to
subscribe to my youtube channel you know
I try to put videos out every day and I
didn't put one out yesterday I was just
I was just too busy I'd have a dash cam
installed in my car and my wife said
well the only take you an hour and three
hours later time you got weights you
know that the service place and all that
that's why I just I wasn't able to get
it get it get we get one recorded
yesterday so anyway thanks for watching
this and have a great day bye-bye